I think we all have a ghosting story in
this generation it's just what you do
now that's a good thing
um I once just wasn't into a guy I
wasn't him first but then over time I
had like other guys that were around and
I had to start like weighing my options
and he was so nice and I didn't know how
to break it to him
so I didn't ghost right away I slide it
out very slowly but now I feel bad
because guess what happen after that I
got a gold stick this month I wanted to
make a video where a ghostie
confronted their ghoster walking into
this project I had no idea how hard it
would be to cast it people have a lot of
emotions about the topic but nobody
wants to speak with the person that
ghosted them or the person that they
ghost it I even had the casting
Department helping me on this and we had
no luck people feel a type of way about
ghosting and since I already booked
everything for this shoot we're making a
video about ghosts and they're making a
video next door too first I reached out
to the ladies and research and they
found out some pretty good information
about the topic the American dialect
Society even named ghosting the word
most likely to succeed in 2015 whatever
that means and the Oxford English
Dictionary added in the new definition
of ghosting in 2016 here are some of my
colleagues reading these ghosting facts
the earliest entry of ghosting into
urban dictionary was in 2007 and it
reads two ghosts
cutting off all ties with a girl that's
so me where's my macchiato at their line
guys just think the camera just read the
line ghosting is a strategy people use
to end relationships in which they cease
all contact with a former partner
instead of formally breaking up with
them okay I'll read the rest one could
argue that dating apps had something to
do with the popularization of this term
tinder was founded in 2012 and became
popular in 2013
mainstream media began using this term
around that time but it became
inescapable around 2014 and 20
team new dating trend has everyone
terrified for those who experience
ghosting firsthand it can definitely
feel unnatural and very unexpected
ghosting is not new to me you all just
pick it up on how to do it and like many
other words used in pop culture this one
may have originated from hip hop Jane
Solomon from dictionary.com speculates
that it might have originated from a
phrase that was very popular in 90's hip
hop get ghost which means to leave
immediately all night wake up is six lil
mama Gregg big geeks ghost at 2016
survey by plenty of fish found that out
of 800 Millennials 78% of them reported
being ghosting so if this happened so
often
why does it make us feel so shitty and
why do we keep doing him so I've been
ghosted once it's not very pleasant it
started from a tinder match okay let's
just have a date on Valentine's Day
which is like a month away but before
that we would face time we would talk
until like 2 a.m. 3 a.m. like almost
every night for a month
come Valentine's Day I had like what's
my little gifts ready to surprise her at
dinner and she was like sorry I can't
make it tonight something came up
and then blocked me from my Instagram
from like text messages everything yeah
it sucked wasting a month of my life
just like investing time to this I don't
know what it was a relationship or a
FaceTime it might be easy to feel like
the person who cut you off is a complete
piece of but there might be more
reasonable explanations as to why this
person goes to you in order to get more
answers about the topic I reached out to
Jasmin Diaz a celebrity matchmaker and
dating expert there are two different
types of people that goes there are
those that just don't care they don't
really care about how you feel they just
live in the motions of their everyday
life and they go from person to person
and then there's those people who fall
in the category of maybe apprehensive
nervous daters and I find that more
times than not you'll come across the
people who are you know really excited
about dating and anxious more so than
those that are just outright jerks
psychologist Susan qalaat said that
ghosts are still like ghosting is the
kind of thing to do opposed to telling
you their actual feelings but if you're
the one being ghost it it doesn't feel
like the kindest thing
I was dating this guy for a month and he
wanted to get really serious really fast
he was excited about the idea of us
being together and I was I was along for
the ride like I was having a good time
he was really cute I really liked him
and then we had a date scheduled and
then he said oh I have to work late at
work like I'm really sorry I feel bad
and I was like okay no that's fine we
all have to work late work comes first
so the day after he postponed their date
I was feeling kind of flirty and I
texted him I just like miss you he did
not respond to that the next morning he
texted me saying that he felt awful but
he had to postpone the second
rescheduled date that we had because his
friends were displaced by the wildfire
that was happening in LA and he had to
like take care of them make sure they
were fine honestly fantastic excuse like
be a good friend support your friends
the wildfires were terrible
like full disclosure this guy was an
excellent texture up to this point
prompt responses like he was clearly
very in it we talked every single day
for almost a month I waited two days
until texting him again I'm like okay
just check again want to see how you're
doing it's been a minute no response
maybe he's dead maybe he's dead he's not
dead because he's watching my Instagram
stories and I can see that I don't know
if he knows that I can see that but I
can see it not just watching one of them
watching all of them all the way through
and I'm like this guy's ghosting me I've
had a few guys just straight up say hey
I'm not looking for anything right now
or I'm not interested and I say hey
thanks for being straight up we move on
with our lives it's all good it takes
literally like 15 seconds but also like
if you get if you ghost after like one
date or whatever it's not that serious
so why do we feel so crushed when we're
ghosted it just sucks to not know where
you stand with an individual you know
you may go out on a date and feel like
the date was great right you had a great
time the conversation was wonderful and
all of a sudden that person disappears
so of course you're gonna be
disappointed you're gonna be broken
heart and possibly and want to know what
happened what went right what went wrong
I think ultimately it's just a normal
human nature type of thing to want to
know where we stand about things I
actually had a client who was with
someone for a number of years and then
all of a sudden the gentleman just
disappeared didn't called it in texting
right just was gone and several months
later it was revealed that he felt like
well you know maybe our relationship was
going in the wrong direction and I
didn't really know how to tell you so I
thought it was easier to just kind of
gently ease back she said it took her
roughly two years to really trust
anybody again personally I feel like the
worst part of being ghosted is feeling
like you're not good enough but the
reality is that you are and somebody out
there will see that one day
I kind of ghosted this guy once and then
I ran into him and then he texted me
mean things about my penis
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]